you're telling me uh when we're eating
there
of all the places you've seen in the
world the places that are the most
interesting to you are all in the middle
east and that is correct
um so where have you traveled there i've
been to turkey many times
egypt obviously i've lived in israel
jordan
lebanon saudi arabia qatar saudi arabia
uae but dressed up in dressing room so
saudi arabia i couldn't dress like this
okay they're culturally not ready for
people to be walking their streets
dressed like this
you know women were just allowed to
drive about two years ago and they're
opening up and i like the way that's
happening but i walk around bahrain and
uae like this and i've only gotten
positive
seriously yeah they they really love i
think everybody they're very very
open-minded people and they're very
friendly the tolerance there is amazing
especially the uae why are you doing
this you like the adventure of it or
it started off purely out of just an
adventure like right
for a jewish kid to be hanging around in
saudi arabia it's like the wildest thing
ever
so that's what originally enticed me to
go there but once i went and i
saw the interactions that i was able to
have with people people changed my
perspective on
on that region and those people and then
i'm able to change their perspective
on my people right when and it's just so
powerful and like addicted to it
let's say who to believe three years ago
that a hasidic jew
and a muslim from saudi arabia could be
together
having a nice afternoon together it
would have seemed impossible but today
we live in a crazy world
and it's totally possible i can't tell
you it's possible it is possible
it is possible peace can be
made
[Music]
okay you're sort of going against the
narrative of hasidic jews who you said
are somewhat insular enclosed in
and very much tight-knit you're going
out to these places that
no one else is right so i mean it sort
of started a trend like
i get calls like almost on a daily basis
like i'm going to saudi arabia can you
you know can you help me meet some
people or can you give me an itinerary
what should i do is it safe are they not
gonna kill me i'm like no don't worry
you're gonna be fine
so i was in the uae a couple of weeks
ago i wanted to go to this ghost town
called al madam it's about an hour
out of dubai and when i got to this
place one of the roads that was supposed
to take me there is literally through
the desert over
sand dunes and my car was not going to
make it right and it was like a two-hour
walk or something so there's no way i
couldn't walk through that heat for two
hours each way
so basically i i parked my car and i put
i started typing into my gps the uh my
hotel i'm gonna go back to the hotel
that's it
a suv stopped near me and i was a little
bit worried because i'm this acidic jew
in the middle of the desert now we're
out of
dubai and you're just like this i was
dressed like this okay
and this guy this guy comes up to the
window and he's like
what are you doing here so i told him i
was looking for alma diamond said oh
you're in the wrong place there's
another road that can take you there
give me your phone
and i'll type it into your gps i'll give
you the coordinates and then you can go
so i gave him my phone and said you know
what i'm gonna take you there
come into my jeep and i'll drive you
there and i'll bring you back to your
car when we're done
and then he said you know what i want to
take you to see my friends
so he's so i stayed in my car he stayed
in his he drove down a road i followed
him for like five minutes
and then he took me into his modulus you
know what a modulus yeah the modulus i'm
sure you've been in them in the middle
east like this room where the head of
the house accepts
receives his guests okay so they have
these low couches and then
and the carpets and whatever and i just
sat there with these guys there were
seven
guys and we played card games and drank
tea
and and just for two hours we're sitting
there a hasidic zoo with seven of these
arabs
and we had the nicest time ever wow it's
just
wow the the people who like that guy
could have just gone on with his day he
didn't have to
stop for me specifically at a massive
jew like i wouldn't expect him to stop
for me
sure and he just he didn't go on with
his day he stopped for me he invited me
into his
home he wanted me to meet his friends we
had the greatest time it's the people
like that who really make a difference
in the world he changed my perspective
and because i'm somebody who
who writes and shares my experiences
he's going to change the perspective of
so many others and that's why it's so
important to
be one of those people who
who changes people's perspectives in a
good way well the arab world is so
hospitable
yeah you know it's like and like
probably the most hospitable part of the
world
yeah and if you if you're reading the
headlines like all the news that comes
out it's not good news there's a lot of
bad news coming out of the middle east
but
if you just open your mind to to go in
there for yourself and just you know
don't don't get too deep into it don't
don't risk your life just just step down
get off the plane
get a feel for what's going on you're
gonna be very pleasant saudi for me was
a huge eye-opener
i had some apprehension going in there i
went i was there before you were there
because i went the first time right
after they killed khashoggi
yeah so they opened up for 30 days there
was this
uh this car festival and yeah
in old riyadh and they gave a thousand
tourist visas i was one of those people
so i was literally one of the first
tourists to see saudi arabia in modern
history
and then last year september they opened
up again which was yeah you went
so it was it was very weird at the
beginning like i was i was
before i got on the plane i was
literally having like a panic attack
yeah i was like
they killed that guy and i'm jewish and
then yeah
i got there and everything was so
peaceful
yeah i'm so glad i i decided not i
literally was gonna cancel i was looking
at him like i'm just gonna give up my
flight i was looking like this this is
too scary i'm just gonna
go home and that was a bad mistake and
then
my rabbi convinced me to go i what's
happened he's like
do it man do it you'll be fine said he
told me if your wife gave you her
blessing to go
you're gonna be safe so i was like okay
wow i went and it changed my life
you